انقلاب تركي سوري على اجتماع موسكو بعد
تصريحات الرئيس التركي اردوغان التي
اعتبرت ان سحب الجيش التركي من شمال سوريا
سيشكل ضعفا امنيا لبلاده وجانب السوري
يشدد على لسان وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل
المقداد ان وجود القوات التركيه
والمجموعات المسلحه في شمال غربي سوريا
يجب ان ينتهي وانا لقاء الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد مع اردوغان برهوم بذلك التصاعد
التركي السوري جاء بعد اجتماع موسكو
الاخير واعتبره البعض تعويما دبلوماسيا
لاردوغان قبيل انتخابات الرئاسه في جولتها
الاولى ولاجل ذلك لم يصمت كثيرا وعادت
تصعيد بين الطرفين الى الواجهه من جديد
وبالعناوين نفسها ما يضع اعلان موسكو بمهب
الريح وفق الخبراء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات